hi and welcome to another episode of not
too deep I'm your host grace Helbig
today we have Tom copper with us he is
an amazing stand-up comedian we talk
about his new Netflix special you're
doing great
it's very motivational it's very
enjoyable it's very it's a very
feel-good comedy special we also talked
about his love of bread and we learn a
little bit about how you make bread this
is an educational episode and we finally
cracked the case on his illustrious
career in b-movie it's an important
question everyone to know what it's like
to be part of the meme of all memes
movie b-movie enjoy this episode of not
too deep with Tom papa Tom thank you for
being here I just watched your special I
love it it's absolutely wonderful it's
just so pleasant though you're talking
about you know the world that we live in
that we get consumed with social media
their own like you know where we're at
it's a very nice it's almost like a life
coaching session yeah I feel like have
you ever considered getting into the
world of life coach yeah I haven't I
have been getting that response a lot
yeah especially
yeah I saw Patton Oswalt was saying that
it's like a veiled pep talk great and I
I am pretty optimistic by Nature
mm-hmm and good for you onto that yeah
and I just I just and it just kind of
started coming out that way like as I
was touring I would tell people yeah in
the audience that they're doing great
yeah any because it really just made me
think like people have this feeling like
they're not doing enough but i thats
nothing's changed other than our
expectation
yeah and seeing other people's
supposedly just this false stuff on
media and we're curated yeah so I just
started telling people no you realize
this is as good as it gets
yeah and that doesn't have to be a very
pessimistic way to think about me right
it's not at all it's actually no this is
really the way it is and freeing in a
way yes
like you're doing great and people would
come up to me after the shows and with
all sincerity thank me really thank you
for saying that
because I've really been feeling
something yeah you don't know that you
need that little bit of encouragement
sometimes
yeah and it's and for me like performing
and you get you're on stage and people
are applauding people don't get
applauded every day you know what I mean
yeah so anyway it just kind of led that
way and it just had this I just started
thinking you know most comedy is very
cynical and negative and I said well I'm
this isn't the way this material is
going and I'm not gonna alter it I'm
just going to be sincere and optimistic
how cool and he was kind of funny
because and it worked and it was like
people really enjoy it and it's all good
but people would ask me in interviews
like so like they didn't trust me
because I am a comedian they're like you
really mean we're not doing great right
you really mean the world is not so but
I really was sincere and I think it's a
weird thing today
it is it is a weird like level of trust
with someone especially a comedian that
you're like where's the sarcasm here
yeah where's the actual like doomsday
yeah mantra going right now but that's
nice so you kind of let it evolve
organically just based on like the
feedback and the yeah and I just kept
going with it and then it kind of it
kind of just started to set in a certain
way and then and it's only after it's
come out that that like you're back to
your original question which I didn't
even answer I've never thought of being
a life coach I can't be a life coach but
I do feel like a little bit of a bit of
a know-it-all like I consider myself
like in this realm I kind of feel like
yeah you should probably listen to me
rather than the person telling you to
give up especially because you talk so
much about social media and it's the
world that we live in and you're so
inundated with messages all day long
like you say in the special to of people
being like get out there and [ __ ]
kill it today yeah yeah when you don't
necessarily like that's an insincere
kind of motivation I think
yeah I'm also curious about because you
talked so much about social media what
is your relationship with social media
because you've been on Twitter since
2007 yeah
that's not bunker yeah but not really
like that active I guess yeah like I
just ya know it is kind of it's it's
weird that it started that well also
yeah that's that here like that it's
been over a decade that Twitter is
existed I feel like it was yesterday
that I saw Michael Ian Black using it
for them right you know it's like whoa
we're supposed to do this yeah yeah um I
I enjoy it but I don't digest a lot of
it that's healthy I don't go through I I
made a decision like I don't know maybe
three years ago then I'm not going
through the feed oh good for you
excuse me I'll go through my mentions
and messages but I've net I have and I
it's weird it wasn't like quitting
smoking or something I think I don't do
that anymore
uh-huh and I don't I just don't go
through this so I don't see the chatter
of all the stuff and talking to my
friends that do yeah I can tell they're
like kind of like shaky and frazzled and
and I just don't I just don't do that
and it made it so much better yeah and
when this special came out it was so
overwhelmingly positive the reaction was
so positive that for the first time I
was like I'm gonna check my mentions
yeah it's good to watch look at people's
comments because they were all it was
just love love love so it was really
cool feedback
I'm also very sensitive to it all are
you yeah so like when people make
comments that that are negative they do
rattle in my head for a bit because I
think probably all of us but for me I
just know that I'm not I take it all
very personally hmm like if people were
to misinterpret something I said on a
podcast or something and come at me for
and it really like it took me a while to
be like just don't respond and don't and
just blow it off I really was like no
don't you don't you understand that I
was trying to say this they don't even
they're not acting with that sincerity
so why am i yeah and hung up
but I think that's why I could start
talking about it in the act is that I do
feel like we are the first human beings
that have had to deal with this yeah
this mental thing at every level I've
got kids I've got friend you know myself
it is something that has to kind of be
managed because it's you know the mental
thing is how we run our lives and it's
affecting it for sure yeah and there's
no blueprint to the effects the
long-term and short-term effects you
have all of this social media on us
we're kind of experiencing it in real
time right now yeah I mean for being
super positive and I think it's so great
to see different groups and different
cultures and everybody like we're able
to like relate to each other in a new
way and yeah there's so much that's
positive but then there's a darkness
that that also intercedes and I think
that I just am very conscious of trying
to manage it yeah and and looking at
like my kids and trying to manage it for
them and because how old are your kids
14 and 17 oh so they're in that sweet
spot of the social media being yeah yeah
you know life force completely
yeah and it's uh and it's weird because
I'll i know exactly when they walked
into the room i know if they've been on
their phone or not really a hundred
percent is coming in the bleary-eyed and
they're kind of like catatonic and
something just happened that you don't
know what and then other times they just
walk in and you know that they're you
haven't been on their phone it's a
lightness lightness and they're talking
to you and you're just like they're
present uh-huh so it's a heavy thing
it's not you know it's a lot of jokes
made about it but it really is a heavy
mental thing and yeah and I think you
just have to find what works for you you
know but I think that's I think it's
great it's a nice like breath of fresh
air because you're not sugarcoating
anything you're calling things as they
are but you're also reminding people
that nothing really matters no it
doesn't it's important to hear that so
the feedback has been very positive has
been very sincere yeah you get a lot of
really heartfelt messages or people
coming up to you after shows yeah
'unless on on social media to people
after shows for sure yeah I mean what's
cool about that is it's just you know
I've been around enough where people
like come up and they're like you got me
through this really hard time or you
know this we had this I mean and the
tragedies are you know profound yeah and
to know that like somebody was watching
my special over and over and over again
this is my even before this one you know
like in the hospital well they were like
you know what I mean like that's a it's
you're always caught up in what am i
doing with my career where is it going
and you know all that kind of stuff and
then there is that real sincere again
thing that like no this woman my special
for my jokes got her through this worst
time in her life yeah everything which
is really crazy to digest yeah and then
to and now I'm getting all of these
messages saying you know I needed to
hear this in this special I needed to
hear this message now because my kid is
sick I lost my job my parents just just
moved away like all this like long list
of and you can tell like some of them
are you know there's that thing on all
of our devices like if the message is
six inches long you're like okay this is
either crazy or this is really yeah
and that is something honestly I didn't
take lightly I don't take lightly being
able to laugh and have a good time and
and what that does for us yeah but I did
I didn't I guess I didn't really
anticipate the impact of it yeah it's
hard to project you know what could be
people's you know interpretations of
this and use you know mention that
you're like sensitive to the feedback
that yeah when it comes in that sincere
and that's sort of like with gravitas
that right there's probably for you like
it hits you in a very powerful way yeah
it does and in yeah in the negative way
in the positive way so it's and then I
always feel bad when they asked for like
a picture keys trying to picture my
now I go bad or something well you hear
I'm also from New Jersey originally and
so it was a point to record this special
in New Jersey why just because because
it's you know a place near and dear to
your heart obvious yeah this is my
fourth one and I'd never shot it ended
up in in New York and other places but I
was like consciously wanted to do it in
New Jersey yeah I felt like the timing
was right and I do still really have an
affection for the for the state yes and
Newark and Newark is like it was in
Newark that it was a newer yeah oh and
it's just you know New Jersey has this
long list of beautiful legendary cities
that are really bombed out yeah through
corruption horrible horrible governance
of the people and there's all these good
people in all of these places really
trying to do stuff and bring them back
like sake and Patterson and Trenton and
glammed in and it's ridiculous that
these great places this far from New
York yeah are just like struggling and
bombed out and there's my sister runs
this nonprofit in Clifton which is kind
of like where the Giants play they're
converting all of these abandoned farm
lands in northern New Jersey was the
Garden State I know and she's found all
these abandoned farms and she's
converting them and bringing people in
from schools and these kids have
learning gardens and it's like these
small efforts yeah it's bad yeah that
are really having an impact and I feel
like there's there's some success
stories like Jersey City or Asbury Park
mm-hmm where they were in the same state
the same condition and people went in
and got motivated and changed it mhm and
now a spur a park is back to what it was
like in the 40s which is this great
beautiful place with Victorian homes on
the water and it's just like an amazing
amazing thing so anyway that's I felt
like anytime we can kind of shine a
light on those
and then have the opportunity to talk
about it I think felt like the right
move that's great you know do you you
this is your sister that's doing these
gardens and this home yeah green it's
called city green do you feel inadequate
to your sister doing that sort of work
because it's a nonprofit as much as I
like making people feel nice and giving
a positive message to the world I want a
nice car no I do but she is a she is she
has a deeper moral character than I do
wait and I read that your brother's a
sportscaster no no no that's not my
brother the Internet is spreading a line
I think that's a new thing because I've
been asked that a couple times it's also
such a strange factoid to be false under
your name years people asked are you
related to Bob papa
and there's another I think that's a
great pop or something who is another
sportscaster and for years people would
just ask are you related and now people
are saying definitively so you're
brothers
yeah wikipedia has created this
relationship for you funny yeah no I
don't know him I have an uncle Bob but
he's not in broadcasting he's in Florida
still time dingo he's still in the
sports game you know what's it like you
know touring so much I ask all stand-ups
this because I'm always so curious it is
such a bizarre life that you guys have
you know show to show state to state
like the city do you enjoy it still I
mean you've been doing this for so long
I really enjoy it and it's interesting I
never really thought it was weird
really yeah until very very recently oh
I was in a hotel somewhere in the middle
of the winter like near Fargo or
something I mean this it's not a lot of
people like checking into this hotel
yeah and I'm just laying on this I just
hit me like look at where you are which
I never do I just go you know what
reflected and I'm like there's a funny
lamp and a weird window and this heaters
with you know strange boys and my kids
are 3,000 miles away what are you doing
exactly it is weird but you know the
whole thing is like standing up in front
of a crowd yeah and being the one person
talking that's weird
very strange there's a lot you really
can't kind of my my motto is don't do
the math yeah on anything how long have
you been together how long have you been
doing this podcast
yeah don't add up all the stuff cuz it's
too daunting yeah just kind of lived in
in the moment and keep going but
whatever once in a while of course I
naturally do the math so I I was I was
doing that just like yeah this is a
weird thing but I do really really enjoy
it yeah do you write on planes yeah I
write a lot on planes oh that's good I
mean that feels like a you know flying
think-tank yeah as long as it's not too
rough of a ride yeah the turbulence can
mess up a plan of I have I've had a lot
of writing in the last like three four
years where I just have haven't these
radio shows in these books the stand-up
and all this stuff so I haven't
literally haven't seen a movie on a
plane in like three years
Wow because it's it's just every time I
have a moment I can open up a laptop and
keep writing and go well that's how it's
gonna you you produce so much content
yeah you're you're standing up your
radio shows the special your YouTube
channel everything we do you ever take a
break like I do any sort of like I'm
just I'm not gonna put things out into
the world right now it's not about
putting it's not as much like I have to
put out of every day when it's but I'm
always creating every day okay you know
what I mean like yeah I'm always writing
for something that's going to come out
or waiting for something but but I know
I don't I was actually at the
supermarket the other day and I cook a
lot sorry I know everyone there and that
the cashier said
she had a day off tomorrow and it's been
like eight days cuz when when is your
day off you you are you weekends are you
when is your day off I was like and
again like the moment in the hotel like
oh I haven't thought about that I don't
question I just realize I don't have
those and even on a day that you know
that I think is going to be a day off I
crave them uh-huh
but I will have done a morning radio
show and then wrote a little something
the problem is and it's not a problem
but the the reality is I enjoy it
well that's I was gonna say I feel like
if you are getting actual like enjoyment
and pleasure out of the you're doing
then why would you sit and reflect on
how many days in a row you've been
working what am I gonna you know I enjoy
sitting and writing so much more than
sitting and doing nothing
yeah and to try and sit there you know
and get through a show or just it's I I
don't too much it's too much it's who's
got the time I know not here I've
literally I interviewed an actor for um
on a better call Saul mm-hmm and I was
like I felt bad because I'd like to be
you know you wanted you know at least
some at least be able to fake it right
and and I have not seen that you love
Breaking Bad and I saw maybe one of
better call Saul and I have not seen
that you're like I really should see it
and it's four seasons in and I'm like
that is a lot of hours I wanna see them
yeah your intentions are good
yeah but the execution is just daunting
it was like I am watching the marvelous
mrs. Maisie
it's about comedy I know Kevin Pollak
and I have to watch this show and I open
my laptop I got through 20 minutes I'm
like what am i doing
gosh I know who's got the time that I
haven't started either of those shows
yeah me neither
no occasionally when we have guests on
here that are you know from TV or film I
I do the like the cleaners cross youtube
search for someone that's put a cut down
together like smart yeah like here's
what you missed the first season so
there's a life hack for you yeah that's
a great oh my god okay we're gonna take
a quick break when we get back I want to
get into the whole cooking side of
things and fascinated by this I got to
know if you're in the Food Network
family now because it seems like a very
illustrious like fraternity that I want
to be part of I will be right back with
more not too deep did you know that
there's a company that's mastered the
science of sparkle meat light box lab
grown diamonds they hacked a
billion-year process to grow stunning
lab-grown diamond stones in about two
weeks and they're some of the highest
quality stones that exist they're always
near colorless always vs clarity always
a very good cut and always $800 per
carat they come in three colors to white
blush pink and soft blue after they're
grown in the lab they're transformed
into gorgeous lab-grown diamond jewelry
it's Beauty meets brain go to light box
jewelry dot-com slash Grace and use code
grace for $25 off that's light box
jewelry dot-com slash grace use code
grace for $25 off okay let's talk about
the baking the cooking the food of it
all how and where did this start for you
have you always just been interested in
that world I've always been interested
in cooking mm-hmm I come from an Italian
family okay in New Jersey and everybody
that's kind of the way that we bond
right is through food and making it for
each other and eating it and and so I've
always been and my mother's a great cook
and my grandmothers were and
we're one one was better than the other
but so I've always been into it and then
I'm not baking I always thought it was
something that was too precise yeah it
is very it's intimidating to me yeah
exactly
it's too it's there's a there's not a
lot of room for failure not a lot of
room for failure or creativity right
yeah exactly
and so but then a friend of mine taught
taught me or just talked about we're on
a TV show together writing and he told
me about making sourdough bread and this
sourdough starter which I'd never heard
of before it's like this living organism
that is basically the wheat that do you
know this heard about this before but I
don't know the dynamics of it
it's like flour and water go into a bowl
and then the yeast that's around us just
floating around go in and eat it okay
and it starts to become this bubbly
little mass Wow and then it becomes this
bacteria in this organism and that's
like we're the first yeast came from wow
so that's what people put into bread and
then instead of this flat just flour and
water right matzah it became bread and
so it's a science fiction kind of thing
I didn't know there was useful around us
I didn't know any of this right you make
that sound very like dangerous and fun
yeah like mad scientist and I told that
story of my dinner table and my daughter
for Christmas got me started a starter
for me very sly she's like yeah and then
my friend max max Werner who was this
great writer he gave me some of his
starter uh-huh and I just started
messing around with it and it's it's
baking but it's more like cooking like
there is room for error like you have
there's a you have to be pretty precise
about some of it but there is also this
more just a kind of a room for it I
guess okay and I just got obsessed with
it I don't know what it was but it just
kind of clicked in and I just got I
couldn't believe I was making these
beautiful
it was insane I was like
literally Finnair yeah literally and it
was this great bread and it was better
for us it was just you know you start I
started to really go down this wormhole
and I started to like compare these
breads to what was being eaten by myself
and my family our entire lives
SuperMario that we thought was really
good bread they had like a wooden carved
sign on the lathe and seeing that it's
filled with sugar and all these
preservatives in and I just got so
excited about it and I couldn't believe
though so that we were the first
generation that wasn't allowed to eat
bread that made no sense to me yeah like
why after thousands of years we show up
and we're not allowed to eat bread and
people have suffering from yeah wait no
I'm like this something's wrong and when
I started making this flour water salt
and yeast for ingredients that's all
that goes into real bread I was like I
just got hooked on it I knew it was a
good thing to bring into the world so I
just kept going and I would visit
bakeries and I would learn how to do it
I would just kind of like you know and I
wouldn't go in the back and like I would
see what flour they were using out
strike up conversations start following
them on Instagram any kind of like
obsession that you do yeah yeah and it
just became a huge part of and still a
huge part of my life I just do it all
the time and I'm trying to get better at
it and I still fail I had a disaster
yesterday that was like a hockey puck
well that's a is that part of the appeal
though is that you know you never know
what the end product is gonna actually
turn out yeah it is very analogous to
comedy where you can get really good at
it yeah it is a craft you can get really
good at it but that doesn't mean that
there's not trouble waiting for you
around the corner really this could be a
horrible night even as good as you are
it could be horrible and it's very
similar and but you know I know I just
it's just this great added thing and
it's really kind of do you do you get
into like the great British
I do like watching that yeah Mary Barry
Paul Hollywood all of the head
yeah I'm obsessed I love them very much
fun week is my favorite week on Great
British Bake Off a great brush baking
show I didn't even know they had that Oh
get into it oh yeah you'll love it bread
week yeah every every season there's a
bread week and it is one of my favorite
America there are some masterpieces in
there are some real disasters yeah and
it is heart-wrenching and I like just
like the pace of that it's so different
than American shows yes the the drama
that happens quote-unquote is so
peaceful and so handled yeah I know then
you go over the Food Network and they're
like in your face exactly oh yeah it
really drives me crazy but you had a
show on Food Network I did it was called
baked yeah and they caught wind of my
habit of touring around the country and
visiting bake recently thought let's
make that into a show yeah so I it was a
natural fit it was just like this really
cool thing to do in visiting these
bakers I mean I think that some of the
greatest people you can meet their hours
are they're insane they weren't really
hard yeah any kind of like little
daydream I would have of opening a
bakery was like no like 3 a.m. or
something baby yeah yeah like you walk
into a place and you see like a counter
filled a case filled with pastries and
all this Hey I always thought in my head
though those are just always there yeah
maybe these people that are making those
every day it was like this is hard hard
work yeah but it most of it comes from
love like they got into it a lot of
people left other careers or they did it
through their family just for the love
of it yeah that really separates the
ones that are mediocre to the great ones
literally in the taste of whatever
they're making Wow the heart and soul is
something really really palpable it's
taste it's real and so I would meet
these people and it was really fun we
did one season of it and something it
was really well really into it but they
just kind of buried it when it came
and they put it like I'm Labor Day night
at 10 o'clock at night hot spot I've had
shows that have been you know dear a
little before and how they're telling
you with all sincerity no that's a good
really when everyone's driving home
Labor Day yeah thank you what an honor I
stand corrected
and it was there and then the next one
was like the Emmys literally really bad
so I don't know what went down but I
have an inkling that this was the only
travelogue show okay
I'm Food Network everything's
competitions now except for Guy Fieri's
Empire yeah don't think I don't and
there's some reason why that is the most
popular show on the network yeah and
there's no duplicates of that show on
the network there's literally no I don't
know why Matt guy I did meet guy how was
that it was a very nice guy this is way
before I baked bread okay
and I had some other show that was on
the air at the time and we were at the
gate at an airport and struck up a
conversation and we I think we're at
some same mbc event are seeing him yeah
a very nice guy yeah I know he's
motivated I know he yeah I know he it's
slash-and-burn with people with
competition mm-hmm
I'm not saying it was him question marks
one bakeries bagels and didn't make any
sense it was two below I know every time
you go to the Burbank Airport you get to
see that guy Yeti little pop-up face
it's so funny I literally saw that the
other day yeah I was going up to Seattle
last week anyway this is where I have to
fire in flames
okay I
went with a friend to the guy fatty
restaurant in Times Square one time for
like a fun you know thing yeah and they
were actually closing like two days
later oh really
first of all the place is monstrous it's
like three weird scattered floors how
they pay that rent blows my mind
but our server was like yeah the we're
shutting down in two days there was just
garbage everywhere like no one was
cleaning any tables and he just had an
entire bottle of sky vodka and it was
like cope with that music we're all like
basically looting the restaurant because
we didn't find out till yesterday oh my
god this is perfect enhancing and
elevating my experience right now thank
you so much better than if everything
was going alright great well rest in
peace too so rest in peace and but so
many people
we're hitting me up forever on to ask
how it was done right how do you make it
how do you do it you've inspired me that
people were like really like wanted to
get into it so I just started posting
stuff on YouTube showing people how to
do it and you know just to kind of keep
that nothing going and it's funny like
my we they've ran the show again on
cooking or like maybe it is coming back
and maybe it's not and I didn't really
want to spend any of my show business
anxiety on the thing that was bringing
you joy hold like a meditative like
exactly I'm like I really want things to
go in my career this is like if it
happens it happens
but then after doing it and meeting all
these people and having the response I
was like they made me want it again
dammit now now it's just like getting a
sitcom on the air and and my daughter
said something in her in her 16 year old
wisdom was I just feel like you're going
to do this show eventually and it might
not be for 15 years but yeah you're not
stopping and it's just going is doesn't
matter if it's this year or not that was
like wow that makes perfect sense
Wow she through your own sort of like
wisdom - yeah it's you totally did I'm
like yeah so I'll just put them on
YouTube that's the other thing as you
know yeah you don't need to take
meetings and get network
to say yes to you if you want to make
something these days you just make it
you can just make it anyone can make
anything anything yeah literally
anything it's overwhelming you know I
don't know how many people are watching
it but I just put it up with like a week
ago come on and just let's just do it
there yeah then you have the freedom
you're not waiting for execs to call you
and tell you when which awards show
night you're gonna you can watch it on
Labor Day night or you can watch it the
next night while you're at the bar for
Labor Day that's right perfect screw you
Food Network's how do your your you have
two daughters yes how do they feel about
their dad being you I think they're they
like it I think they like that there's
you know there's they like that I'm
funny and it's a funny house oh that's
good you know what I mean they genuinely
think you're funny yeah that's I can
make them laugh which is good that's
good not all the time you know my one my
younger one she's kind of funny in a
adult kind of way okay you know like a
little cutting and a little she doesn't
you know she's not doing it for approval
right and someone's if she wants to
really like burn me a little bit she'll
hear me making a joke to somebody in the
other room and she'll just go ha jokes
[Laughter]
but I like it so much but I think they
get it they like as the older they get
they realize this isn't kind of like a
normal life okay I think they kind of
appreciate carving out a different path
a lot of the other dads
yeah I think they dig that I think they
like if I can get them close to
something that they enjoy okay if you
can be a link somehow like I might
haven't I might have an end to get to
one of rupaul's brunch thing Wow
that's a major major major major my
daughter is gonna be so pleased with
that
we're stand-up special I they're not
interested they haven't read
my book there's no but if I can get them
to RuPaul's Drag Race
they met Miley Cyrus once it's like then
I get that legitimizes your career in
their eyes now how do you decide with
you know books stand-up everything where
do you decide what stories or commentary
you want to make goes into what do you
have do you kind of like take stock of
that what of where like where you put
this is a joke for the acne for the
bucker yeah I don't it's kind of uh I
kind of feel like it all feeds each
other okay um there are certain things
don't really translate that well like
written like I'll write things for live
from here which is this uh what Prairie
Home Companion used to be mm-hmm that's
called live from here now that's an NPR
show that runs every we can I do these
monologues on it called out in America
yeah and there are you know it's
basically seven minutes of stand-up
mm-hmm you know about me traveling and
trying to shine a light on all the good
people in America right right and and
it's interesting cuz it'll do really
well when I'm there and but for some
reason like you can't just pull those
jokes out and put them in the act right
you can get like an idea but then for
something that and similarly things for
my act don't necessarily they'll go into
a book or a written form but that that's
so abbreviated and cut down that it has
to be kind of be expanded right and put
you know in them so it's just yeah
they're different mediums even though
they're all under the same umbrella did
everything just get louder oh that's oh
yeah you have a volume button right
there I didn't touch the button but all
of a sudden you got so loud and I was
looking at your eyes like am I having a
stroke why are you not reacting I don't
know I have no help medically for you
whatever you're experiencing right now
got it in the middle of the MA
the highest viewed podcast that we've
had aren't you waiting for that though I
mean I hope every time that someone has
a medical malfunction every podcast
fingers crossed
okay back to bread a little bit is it in
your expert opinion okay to pick mold
off of a piece of bread and eat it oh
it's interesting or is that a complete
taboo I think it's probably okay okay I
think it's more okay for cheese yes for
bread it depends how much because like
I'll see mold on bread right my eyes
aren't that great so I'll see mold on
bread and then think it's off and then
think what else am i what am I not just
not see what's more microscopic it's got
to be all through it so I don't know
okay you can probably why do you ask
I haven't done it recently I'm just
curious because I have done the thing
where I've bought a loaf of bread in
like the expectation that I'm gonna like
make sandwiches for myself it doesn't
happen bread sits there and then like a
piece at the end will collect mold and I
sometimes feel a little bad throwing the
entire thing away right and I didn't
know if you had knowledge in the bread
world that I didn't know about if that's
like actually no problem no no now it's
pure instinct I'd say there's more bread
b-movie mmm-hmm you're part of one of
the most memed
movies that's ever been created
how has how has that been to be part of
such a legacy
what's so hilarious is did that movie
and my daughter was my older daughter
was probably five uh-huh and she got to
go to the premiere we wear a little bee
thing was like perfect timing basically
and then I really didn't even know it
was a craze a meme crazy yeah in
probably two years into it being and my
daughters were just like
hey you know that thing is everywhere
and because they have a poster down in
the playroom you know and they know that
I'm one of the bees but they literally
this is how disconnected they are from
any of the career kinda stuff it really
had been going on for a couple years and
I had no clue and like why why is this
hitting she goes I don't know just
something about like a bee having a
sexual relationship and so yeah I try
and I try and squeeze a little of that
out yeah yeah it's it blows my mind
it's a who knows how memes work and why
yeah congratulations on being part of
one of the great puns how do I turn it
to my how do I get anything out of it I
mean this be merch shows cells and stuff
after oh I guess yeah I haven't even
posted like a picture of me as the V
yeah now's the time the craze over I
feel like you can resurrect it it for
DES I feel like everyone's waiting for
someone to get the b-movie meme going
again alright I'll try
when was last time you got a parking
ticket um well a parking ticket mm-hmm
mm parking ticket a little while I
haven't gotten a parking ticket but I
got a toll ticket oh yeah that got like
mailed to you afterwards yeah that's
always I don't like that there's
something very targeted about that
option like I couldn't even I just had
to go through yeah
there's no option they don't look there
I mean I know it's my fault at the end
of the day is it what because you didn't
buy a thing to stick in your car maybe
no is going this way yeah right no I and
there's not enough notification
beforehand and not enough warning to let
me know that I need change or cash or
you guys got to get debit card machines
or something it's not even a little man
in a house which I need to speak to the
manager
he's not there yeah but parking that's
interest oh no I I did get a parking
ticket I would say about eight months
ago in in like Beverly Hills and I just
parked and didn't go to the valet yeah
and then went in and when we came out
the guy I was meeting with went to the
valet and my thing had a ticket on it
and the valets like the valet kind of
thought
yeah the valet was like yeah did that
one yeah it's on you pal Wow
I've never heard of why I know you could
have just waved me I was just confused I
didn't know that that was a possibility
in LA I know what else did we have to
deal with and the world is falling apart
it's against we're gonna be fine okay
we're take one last break when we get
back I have a bunch of Twitter questions
that have been submitted for you so
we'll be right back with more not too
deep do you have a bunch of stuff lying
around the house that you just don't use
a kids baseball glove that no longer
fits that pair of jeans you wore that
one time an old phone hiding in a drawer
somewhere well there's an app you can
use to sell this stuff and it's called
Merc Ari
mercury is the selling app that makes it
fast and easy to sell almost anything it
couldn't be simpler
you just take a few pictures of your
stuff you add a description and boom
your item is listed then once it's sold
mercury emissions and send it off
there's no meetups there's no hassles
with millions of people using the Macari
app in all 50 states stuff really sells
the app has over 500,000 reviews on the
App Store with an average 4.8 star
rating so why not give it a try
don't let that stuff you don't use go to
waste sell it ship it and get paid with
Mercury you can find mercury on the App
Store's or armored-car e.com that's M er
C AR I Merck re the selling app
obviously we all know that life is
stressful and difficult and we could all
use some help sometimes but we may not
know how or where to ask for it and
that's where better help comes in there
online counseling offers licensed
counselors who specialize in
including depression and anxiety as well
as complicated relationships family
relationships sleeping grief stress
trauma and anger
you can schedule secure video or phone
sessions with your therapist plus
securely exchange unlimited messages
simply fill out a questionnaire to help
them assess your needs get matched with
a counselor and start communicating at
under 24 hours and if for any reason you
are unhappy with your counselor you can
easily request a new therapist at any
time for no additional charge get
professional help when you want it
wherever it's most convenient and not
too deep with grace helbig listeners
will get 10% off their first month with
discount code grace that's better help
calm slash grace why not get help better
help calm slash grace okay we are back
and before we get into these Twitter
questions I'm gonna ask you the two
questions I asked every single guest
that has been on the podcast the first
is who alive or dead would you most want
to throw cold spaghetti at Oh alive or
dead yes that I would like to throw cold
spaghetti at I would throw it at Sean
Hannity okay we haven't had that as an
answer so yeah thank you and why I just
feel like he's he's a liar I don't care
what side you're on even if you're like
a real Republican or Democrat just like
he knows what he's doing
yeah yeah and he's inciting people I
don't like people that make other people
unhappy and insightful and based on lies
knows what he's doing that I value an
appreciation hold spaghetti for a liar
yeah yeah the other question is to tell
us your worst or most memorable pants
shooting story but you can only use
three words or three small phrases so
mine is college jogging front lawn
got it grandma card game swimming pool
okay yeah that sounds like a fun fourth
of July
I never saw that bathing suit again okay
let's get into these questions submitted
via Twitter a platform that you don't
like to engage deeply into Nicole wants
to know what experiences from your
career would you use as advice for those
wanting to get into comedy I'm sure you
get the advice question all the time
yeah um I guess the best advice would be
I don't know if it's the best but it's
the best at this moment is finds a
comedian that you respect and hang
around them hmm
like if you're in a if there's a club
where you're starting to try it out yeah
and just find people who you like and
you think are funny and get to know them
and hang around because you'll there's
very few people that can show you like I
could say right more or Jonas or
whatever but that's it's a life kind of
well thing that's the interesting thing
in stand-up I know it a little bit from
the outside looking in at it but there
is a very I don't know what the right
like phrases for it but a lot of people
take people under their wings there's a
lot of like mentorship it seems that
happens in the community whether it's
organic or kind of chosen yeah yeah and
it's a it's a very odd thing that only
certain people really really understand
yeah so still happening everyone needs
an opening act yes very true and the
opening act is usually someone who
really wants to do it and learning so
it's the kind of that mutual thing hmm
and in somebody did it for you right you
do it for them and you know it's not
selfish it's it's not purely the
opposite of selfish selfless thank you
it's a you know you're getting around
somebody who's funny and and you're in
there helping your shows and but yeah
get around people who you really respect
and like and soak it all in
yeah that's great advice yeah because I
think there's a lot
love focus on you know create your
content do your work right do all of
that but it is being right place right
time were around the right like
motivating voices it's confusing it's so
I have somebody that's gone down the
road already mm-hmm it's very very
helpful do you notice any major
differences I'm sure there's a lot from
when you started versus you know present
day you're getting into the space more
yeah I mean there's a lot of really cool
stuff there's definitely a lot more
places to do it right it's not so rigid
in who's doing it where they're doing it
yeah how they're doing it
stand-up has become like music in that
there's classical and there's
alternative and you know there's there's
so it's so varied now great so you can
kind of pick you know certain people
think that oh so and so does this but
it's not comedy that's like a one-man
show that's a or that's not comedy
that's like prop stuff or whatever and
but it's all comedy yeah is and now it's
all being accepted and be all these
audiences are able to pick who they like
and create their little army and fans
and follow that person so that's really
cool the one negative of that of that
span of it is that you can just play to
your like-minded group and just play
there and not be able to make everybody
laugh right and I come from the time
when you just were thrown into bars
where they they weren't expecting comedy
or sent to a nursing home or sent to the
deep south or sent to rich people in New
England and you had to make all of them
laugh equally yeah and that's there's a
power to that yeah you have to get
really strong and then you go back of
course you your group will who likes you
if it's families or if it's young women
or whatever right they'll like you more
right but you're able to be liked by all
of them yeah that to me is the goal is
to be purely funny to everybody universe
funny and I think as the way that people
develop now you kind of pigeonhole
yourself and mm-hmm
and I fear that they won't be able to
have as long careers like the chameleon
effect kind of being able to handle
yourself wherever you are there's safe
spaces and comedy yeah
and interesting comedy is not a safe
space yeah house of trash Twitter's
wonderful wants to know what is it like
to be old it's not the best what's weird
is that I could see I could see where um
there's just you know your knees aren't
as great you can't just jump off of
things anymore yeah I've learned that
having an injury as an adult yeah it has
so much shame to it it's so embarrassing
to you know show up with like your foot
in a boot or something like that there's
just it's not like when you're ten years
old and you play soccer and everyone's
got crutches somewhere it's like very
embarrassed yeah yeah I don't feel I
don't feel it you know my eyes aren't
great my hair is going like those little
vanity things are weird
I'm still like strong like I can
physically do those kind of things but
you could just see it coming anyway you
can just see it coming it's like all
starting to happen and you definitely
you definitely like starting to
understand why people who are much older
or like they almost talk to you like
they're a young person trapped in this
broken-down body that seems like oh yeah
that's how it's gonna go because I
literally what if I talk to a an 18 year
old comedian I don't see them as older
than me right right right I don't I just
I'd see them my wife was always asking
so how old is so-and-so no idea I
literally don't never I don't think
about it and I do think that I'm whoever
I'm talking to I think I'm them yeah but
that goes to your point of view being
able to blend your comedy to whomever
are you being able to assimilate to the
people around you make sense until you
can't see the shampoo or the blow ssin
in the hotel room and you're like oh
maybe I'm not eighteen to look forward
to
Rapunzel Oh once no what are your
favorite kind of chips oh man I would
say right now it's it's kettle chips
salt and vinegar oh but you know it's a
weird one I just got turned on to which
is embarrassing to say I like it was his
kettle chips pickle chip yeah I'm a big
fan you are yeah big fan I like anything
with the pickle flavor the briny oh yeah
it's a little weird to say out loud it
is kind of gross it's really addictive
yeah I mean but also salt and vinegar I
think is good be gross if you think
about it you're just eating vinegar and
crunchy form right now we've just taken
a different type of vinegar chip there's
something worse about seeing a pickle on
the bag Kathryn wants no favorite
childhood memory and favorite job memory
Oh God
what sort of jobs did you have before
stand-up I had lots of jobs um cut lawns
I worked in as a busboy
I worked in factory you did it all yeah
I did a lot of every weird little job I
liked when I'd like I liked when I was
young I liked my favorite moments were
when I was supposed to be working and I
would be getting out of it like I work
for a car company and I found like if
you pull the boxes out in the warehouse
you could climb behind the box and sleep
back like if you just pretended to cut
the lawn you could just let me take a
nap pretend to cut the lawn
he just started up you're working for an
old lady and you tell her see you next
week she won't know the difference
I always like getting out of work for
sure that's great
childhood memory I don't know there's so
I don't know there's so many there's so
I just like I'd like to I'd like to
sleepovers when you were told you were
going to they were going to kill you if
you laughed and if you were noisy
anymore what if like you know if you're
having a sleepover like get to bed you
just you and your friend just cannot
stop laughing those moments are pretty
great fantastic
have you tried having teenage daughters
to assimilate to like what they like and
are into yeah okay yeah is it a
difficult task or do you find that it's
more interesting than difficult it's
kind of it's it's it's pretty
fascinating yeah cuz I you know when
you're young mm-hmm
you don't have to ask what the cool
music is right you never look at a list
no you never look like you just hit you
just live it yeah I don't know how it
gets to you when you're young friends
and it's just but you know exactly
what's good and what's so my whole I
just keep asking them like do we like
her you have built-in resources for your
materials sometimes get the temperature
of the pop culture about things yeah but
there's a lot of it that's really just
unknowable yeah and it depends like
their tastes are different - we were
watching she was watching The Bachelor
the other night yeah and and I I was
there watching it with her just want to
be in the room with her I'm just mocking
it and she's like you can't do this you
can't say you want to be with me and
then rip apart the show that I am
enjoying like you're right you're right
you can't yuck my YUM
but The Bachelor I think is one no
offense to your daughter that is worthy
of making fun of oh my god I haven't
gotten into this season because it hurts
my heart what a horror show
what are they just as women I feel like
what what do you know they do
the best they're doing them everything
turns into housewives and they do like
the after-show and they're all just
awful to each other like housewives
there I mean it's fascinating to me
bachelor makes me a little crazy I think
I like the housewives because there at
least when I started watching they were
you know a natural on above me so I
didn't feel as connected so it was more
interesting to watch but when I watch
like The Bachelor and these are peers in
a way something inherently sad about
what I'm looking at right now I know a
housewives make me sad but still fully
entertaining well that's the thing it's
like you can't read too much into it
just gotta go with the flow yeah and
just yeah she can't be like oh this is
just horrible for my young women to seem
what Heather wants no how nerve-wracking
is it to tape a Netflix special it's
pretty nerve-wracking the whole goal of
when you're shooting a special is to
make it as close to just a live
experience that you've been doing on
tour all year yeah but then all of a
sudden there's cameras and makeup and
all this other stuff going around it and
the nert the audience is more nervous
and it's a little more heightened so you
have to kind of temper it it's pretty so
I would say it's pretty nerve-wracking
yeah but each one gets a little easier
it feels like you're hosting your own
party kind of making sure everyone is
having a good time yeah like there's
nothing better than the show the next
show after that night oh yeah yeah
there's no pressure in the audience is
just there to have fun they're not there
to make your tape and go well right they
want you to succeed so there's a lot of
just like hope in there don't blow it
favorite wait wait moment Diana wants to
know oh I got to host I got to guest
host oh nice yeah which was pretty great
I've always liked that show the whole
thing is great Peter sagal is great
Paula Poundstone is like the legend
she's just amazing and then I got to
guest host it cool and yeah and with her
on the panel and stuff and it's a very
rare thing like not a lot of people got
to do
I'm Hanks did it Wow yeah so that was
funny
yeah that was really that was the moment
so far I love doing it I'm gonna I think
I have two more coming up this year
that's awesome yeah before the summer
very cool
okay this is our last question Becca
wants to know what's the best quality
about the last person you texted what's
the best quality of the last person I
texted or the last person you could
remember I guess that you text you don't
have to pull out your phone and look at
all no I got him in my house yeah it
actually was it actually was my friend
Joanne mm-hmm who works at Netflix and
we were just texting about the special
and the best thing about her is in a she
she's this great person who was a comedy
central for years and is it Netflix now
and she was very involved with it and
was a good friend for all this time I
would have to say that she is a very
truthful loyal person like that's very
like in this business it's very easy to
be put in positions where maybe you let
friendship slide and she is the opposite
of that oh what a lovely quality is
great and so good to hear yeah those
people are in your life Tom thank you
for being here before we wrap everything
up every guest that's on the podcast
gets a personalized fortune cookie
personalized from us to you you'd
obviously don't have to eat it but there
is a fortune in there that is can I open
it now of course yeah it's a it's buried
deep wow it's really really into it
it's it's either really long oh it's
really long oh wow
should I read it would you like to hear
it absolutely
papa Dodd question mark papa
is that you Papa save me
miss cookie Papa oh [ __ ] sorry
wrong guy
Tom where can people find you the
special everything that you're up to if
they don't know go to Tom papa calm okay
that has links to the new book to the
bread videos to the special to the tour
it's all right there everything and
you'll be touring for the next couple
months Instagram all that stuff
it's all Tom papa PAP a grape yeah I'm
touring um heavy till the summer very
cool well make sure you guys go out and
check him out on the road and go watch
the Netflix special it's out now
everyone can watch it I loved it it will
make you feel better because you take a
lot of the pressure off of everyone it's
good in existing in this world oh and my
book is coming out in May oh your book
you're doing great and other reasons to
stay alive right now right now but can
people pre-order now they can okay great
yeah yeah go check that out everyone
thank you again for being here you're
the best good luck on your travels thank
you very much fingers crossed
I'll give you updates please I'll check
your Twitter we'll see you guys next
time on not too deep good bye bye 2deep
2deep 2deep 2deep not too deep is a
production of grace helbig incorporated
producer Melissa D months edited by
Shireen Lonnie Eunice post-production
sound by Chris Henry and an extra
special thanks to Flula for the theme
music meet lightbox lab grown diamonds
they hacked a billion-year process to
grow stunning lab-grown diamond stones
in about two weeks and they're some of
the highest quality stones that exist
they're always near colorless always vs
clarity always a very good cut and
always $800 per carat they come in white
blush pink and soft blue it's Beauty
meets brains go-to lightbox jewelry calm
slash Grace and use code grace for
twenty five dollars off better help
online counseling offers licensed
counselors who specialize in issues
including depression anxiety complicated
relationships grief trauma and more you
can schedule secure video or phone
sessions
with your therapist plus securely
exchange unlimited messages get
professional help when you want it
wherever it's most convenient and you
beautiful listeners will get 10% off
your first month with the discount code
grace that's better help calm slash
grace
[Music]